pourquoi tous les deux vous faites ce
mouvement c'est quoi c'est contre le
kazakh sinal c'est pour le pouvoir
d'achat c'est quoi en tout cas nous
priori de prioritairement c'est contre
le pass vaccinale d'accord qui épie les
mesures liberticides qu'il ya autour de
ça et ensuite il ya aussi d'autres
revendications telles que le pouvoir
d'achat ça fait quand même très
important et qui permettent à beaucoup
de français qui ne permettent pas en
tout cas beaucoup de français de pouvoir
vivre librement voire même de manière
décente alors êtes-vous marisa mali
revendications sont globalement les
mêmes bien entendu d'accord elles mêmes
personnes qui font dans le convoi sans
vous parler de deux mouvements c'est
évident mais c'est un seul convoi
d'accord voilà sur parise la seule
différence est que monsieur avait convoi
de la liberté souhaite entrer dans paris
nous on ne le souhaite pas alors qu'est
ce qui va se passer concrètement pour
les gens qui nous regardent il va se
passer quoi samedi alors vous allez
faire quoi samedi le but c'est de
pouvoir de se faire quand on est avec
des camions dont vous êtes vous êtes
combien de mémoire présenté comme une
personne voilà sincèrement je ne peux
pas vous dire c'est un chiffre à bhl ce
matin il ya eu les premiers départs de
nice d'accord qui représente plus de 100
véhicules sachant qu'il ya plusieurs
personnes dans chaque véhicule donc pour
pouvoir dénombrer le nombre de personnes
qui à peu près ça va être que quasi
impossible à l'époque étant dit les
blues elle vous m ou baddou pour
l'instant le convoi il va donc se
diriger comme on peut voir là sur la
carte on va partir d'un peu partout dans
le temps dans le pays oui de pouvoir
pouvoir converger tous ensemble pour
pouvoir aller vers la capitale qui est
quand même le lieu de pouvoir essayer de
se faire se faire écouter parce que
souvent on nous dit mais on vous entend
mais moi je veux pas être entendu je
vais être écouté vous allez vous allez
vous aller bloquer quoi les portes
des sorties de la jungle et on n'a
jamais parlé de bloquer encore vous
allez rien bloquer donc non on va juste
faire un convoi qui va se diriger vers
la cathédrale pour être écouté ok très
bien donc c'est important l'iae roland
lescure est ce que vous craignez que ce
mouvement dégénère avec la république
qu'on marche avec le gouvernement ou pas
du tout vous ne l'aviez réunir d'abord
j'espère qu'il va pas dégénérer en tout
cas ce que j'entends ce qui a pas mal
fait de bloquer la volonté de
revendiquer et ça j'allais dire je le
reconnais c'est respectable et en plus
franchement c'est des revendications je
comprends bien j'en ai autant marc vous
des contraintes sanitaires de la crise
sanitaire du pass vaccinale et j'espère
qu'on pourra s'en débarrasser le plus
tôt possible moi je considère gelé voter
que c'était une bonne manière de gérer
cette crise sanitaire et ça commence à
payer puisque les cas sont en baisse il
ya encore des morts hier il y avait
trois cent soixante trois personnes ont
perdu la vie dans les hôpitaux français
mais malgré tout ça s'améliore et je
suis convaincu que ces contraintes qu'on
a fait peser c'est vrai essentiellement
sur les gens qui voulaient pas se faire
vacciner eh ben elles ont servi elles
ont été utiles et c'est très différent
d'ailleurs de ce qui se passe au canada
en passant livré dans la tête
aujourd'hui à routier canadien il peut
pas bosser oui c'est ça en france un
routier il peut bosser il peut traverser
une frontière il peut s'arrêter dans un
relais routier même s'il n'est pas
vacciné au canada c'est impossible donc
les revendications sont similaires des
contraintes évidemment sont sans commune
mesure avec ce qu'il ya au canada ce qui
justifie aujourd'hui que la capitale
soit à bloquer liberté d'ailleurs moi
c'est pour ça que vous soutenez le c'est
pour ça que je suis là c'est pour la
spontanéité et justement vous le disiez
monsieur les syndicats routiers hôtes ne
se joignent pas autrement mais ça moi
j'aime que les français pour le pass
vaccinale et pour le pouvoir d'achat
parce que quand on fait ses courses face
à beaucoup de très cher parce que les
tristes et coûte cher parce que le
carburant coûte cher j'aime cette
mobilisation spontanée moi je soutiens
totalement je crois qu'après voulait
aller vers bruxelles bon alors là si le
marisa oui gaylord sais pas si vous
voyez y met mais moi je suis totalement
pour ce mouvement je trouve que c'est
l'expression de la colère des gens belge
herman vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord
on a goûté franchement il ya eu ça fait
trois ou quatre ans il ya eu plein de
mouvements légers jones était spontané
là c'est à copier coller du canada et ça
n'a rien à voir effectivement c'est de
ces deux situations totalement
différente et ça va encore quoi vous en
disiez bloqué empêcher les gens de
bosser empêcher les restes d'avoir des
clients les magasins d'avoir des clients
et une fois de plus moi je moi moi
j'entends évidemment vos revendications
mais on est à la fin de la crise on
espère être à la fin de la crise enfin
recommencer à remettre une pièce dans le
jukebox pour parler des mêmes choses je
pense que c'est des combats qui
honnêtement là et je pense qu'ils sont
plus vraiment audible je pense
sincèrement et moi je pense surtout à
tous ceux qui depuis trois ans ou quatre
ans maintenant n'arrive plus à bosser
ils en ont ras-le-bol d'être embêté
parce que voilà parce que vous avez s'il
arrive puis à beauté à bosser ça à cause
du passé non mais non non parce que il
ya 90 % des projets qui sont vaccinées
dont vous n'êtes pas vraiment tu veux
pas dire qu'on est à la fin de la crise
alors qu'on vient de lancer le pass
vaccinale déjà moi ce qui m'énerve c'est
qu'on veut faire passer ce mouvement
pour un mouvement violent des antennes
wimax
de violence voilà parce qu'il ya au
canada
c'est un mouvement qui disent que j'ai
compris il rassemble des gens de tout de
tout milieu de toutes sensibilités
politiques qui veulent juste exprimer un
ras le bol général ensuite sur la forme
oui c'est une action coup de poing mais
pourquoi coup de poing parce que les
gens ont la sensation de ne pas être
entendus il ya eu des manifestations
entreprise normale en france pendant la
crise sanitaire pardon mais
malheureusement ça n'a servi à rien donc
je comprends le ras-le-bol de ces gens
et bravo à eux sur cette action coup de
poing qui on l'espère fera changer des
choses comme ça a été le cas au canada
parce que suite à ces manifs ils ont
supprimé des restrictions cas c'est pas
con